>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Scott Simon: Really, it
is an honor to talk to you.
It's wonderful.
I'm glad we could do this.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Thank you.
>> Scott Simon: Let me try to
set the story a little bit.
Javier Mallarino, your protagonist,
is the best-known political
cartoonist
in a political environment
that can be lethal.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yes.
>> Scott Simon: I think it's fair to
say, Columbia of a generation ago.
Describe that territory
to us, if you could.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: First
of all, I'd like to thank you
and thank you all for coming, to
thank Mr. Ambassador for his words.
I always have the impression that
ambassadors are always trying
to redress what we
novelists mess up.
[Laughter].
To thank you very much.
Yeah, this novel was written in
2012-2013 at a point in which I had
to explain to readers
outside of my country the fact
that this story the novel tells us
is actually plausible in my country.
It is the story of
a cartoonist who is
so powerful that he is threatened.
He is feared.
He is very well respected.
He is able to change the climate
of political opinion
in very direct ways.
In 2013, this was not
easily understandable
in countries other than mine.
We have a strong tradition of
cartoonists who are actually this --
very powerful people whose
opinions are respected.
Coming from the 19th century, and
in particular, a cartoonist working
in the 20s who was a tremendous
symbol of what the relationship
between political opinion and the
political world was in my country.
His name was Ricardo
Rendon [phonetic].
This is the character but
also tries to put in place.
This person who, through drying
politicians in a national newspaper,
is able to achieve real
political influence
and to model the political
discussion in my country.
>> Scott Simon: Even the
politicians whom he savages are kind
of flattered by it,
because it means they count.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Well, they exist, yes.
They have figured out
that being destroyed
by Javier Mallarino is
effectively to exist
in the political world in Columbia.
But the thing is, that
kind of power in the hands
of a political cartoonist is
not something that my readers
in translation were
used to five years ago.
And this has been a
very interesting,
a very dramatic thing
for me to witness.
Within four years, since the novel
was published in 2013 in Spanish,
the world has changed so much, that
actually is more understandable
that political cartoonists are
influential, because they have been.
In terms of international news,
everybody knows what has happened
with political cartoonists
such as those
in the Charlie Hebdo
magazine in France.
>> Scott Simon: I know you spent
some years living in Paris,
but you wrote this novel
before Charlie Hebdo.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yes.
>> Scott Simon: Before
the terrible crime.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yeah, yeah.
Before that horrible thing.
That happened, I think,
maybe a couple of years
after my novel was published.
It was a couple of years later
because the French translation
had already appeared.
So yeah, it had this weird
coincidence in time for me.
The fact that the novel
was becoming reality
in so many countries in the world.
>> Scott Simon: As the story
opens, the cartoonist is
about to be given the honor of
having his self caricature put
on a national postage stamp.
He comes in contact with a young
woman who he doesn't remember.
She's posing as a reporter, which
by the way, is astonishingly easy.
Takes no knowledge whatsoever --
I'm in some position to tell you.
Let me put it this way, he
comes to terms with the fact
that what he does, does not
always have positive consequences.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: That's more
of the situation explored
in the novel.
Yes. This young lady, we're
not going to reveal too much
of the plot -- don't worry.
Petition lady comes to him
to ask him to remember,
to remember the past, to remember a
night that happened 28 years before
in which something may or may not
have happened at Mallarino's house.
That event, of that night,
caused Mallarino to draw one
of his most famous cartoons.
And this girl, who 28 years
later, she is asking him
to remember what he
saw during that night.
And he realizes that he may not
have seen what he thinks he saw.
That his cartoon, after
all, may be groundless.
This is the situation
explored in the novel.
It was very strange for me to begin
a novel in which my main subject,
my main idea, was the discussion
of the vulnerability of our image
in the hands of people who have
an influence on public opinion.
But as the novel progressed,
I realized I was writing
about something else also.
I was writing about
the vulnerability
of our private memories, the fact
that we are never sure
of what we remember.
This difficult relationship
we have with memory became one
of the main themes in the novel.
>> Scott Simon: There are
lots I could read from.
It's beautifully written
and beautifully translated.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Beautifully
translated by Ann McLean.
>> Scott Simon: I have to ask,
why didn't you do the translation?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Because
Ann McLean would be out of a job.
[Laughter].
She is a friend of mine.
I don't want to do that.
>> Scott Simon: You have
done some translation.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
No, the real reason is
that literature is too difficult
to -- Let's put it this way,
you should always have
done some translation.
I've earned a living
as a translator.
But you translate towards
your own language,
because this is the language
in which you are close to 100%.
I'm not close to 100% in English and
that's something I prefer to leave
in the hands of somebody who is.
And I have this great luck of
having one of the best translators
of Spanish-language
literature in the world.
That doesn't mean I don't
dig in as soon as I can.
We work closely together.
I try to bother her
as much as I can.
But I never lose sight of the
fact that for me as a translator,
one of the worst things
in the world was a writer
who thought they knew my language.
So I try never to be that
writer -- so Ann McLean.
>> Scott Simon: I want to read
a section and ask you about it.
I love this section.
"Life is the best caricature.
Life turns us into
caricatures of ourselves.
We all have the obligation to
make the best caricature possible,
to camouflage what we don't like,
and exalt what we like best.
You will understand, says the
cartoonist, I'm just not talking
about physical attributes, but the
mysterious life traces life leads
on our features, the moral
landscape, if you will.
That moral landscape that gets
drawn onto our face as life goes by,
as we go along making mistakes
or getting things right."
It reminded me, there's a
story of Abraham Lincoln,
who used to be a model for
presidential disposition,
but of course has recently
been replaced.
I'm sorry, I just have to
avoid these cheap jokes.
But Lincoln notably was resisting
the urging of some of his aides
to appoint someone as the
local postmaster somewhere.
And they said why,
and he said, "Well,
because I don't like his face."
And they said, "Mr. President,
you can't refuse to appoint a man
because you don't like his face."
And he said, "Nonsense,
after the age of 40,
every man is responsible
for his own face."
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Very good.
Very good.
I wish you had told me that before.
[Cross-talk].
>> Scott Simon: But help
us understand a caricature
at how the cartoonist sees his art.
Because that has something to do
with literature too, doesn't it?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Yes in a way.
For me to have something to do
with journalism and the terms
that I understood journalism at the
time when I was writing the book.
I used to be a weekly political
columnist in my country.
I did that for seven years.
I wrote political columns
weekly for seven years.
Then I stopped because I was writing
a very long, very difficult novel
that I will inflict
on you all next year.
To have both things at the
same time, it became difficult.
So I quit political
commentary for a while.
I still do it once in a while,
every time something pops
up that makes me angry or indignant,
which is most of the time.
But this idea of -- this particular
relationship we have as columnists
with readers, these
distortions of relationships
that I began witnessing the way
it's very easy to create tensions
in a room just by walking in.
The way I lost friends, the
way I had fights with family.
All my neurosis went into the
character of Javier Mallarino.
So discussing Colombian
political reality
in print was what led directly
to the character and the way
and the position he has, or
rather the relationship he has
with his readers in Columbia.
>> Scott Simon: Is that what
we do with our memories?
Do we caricature our
life experience?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: I
think we streamline them, yes.
I mean, nobody knows
really how memory works.
This is one of the ideas
at the center of the book.
This immense talent memory has
to manipulate us the way --
our memories are obviously
the only window we have
into our past experiences.
There's nothing else.
Obviously, there are
other people's memories,
and this is why we read books.
But this window so fragile,
so easily distorted,
so tainted by subjectivity,
by prejudice,
by whatever we would
have liked to happen.
This is more or less
what we remember.
Or rather, we are very,
very good at suppressing.
Obviously, this is commonplace.
We are very good at
suppressing what we don't like.
So this relationship with memory
became very interesting for me.
How it manipulates us.
How we are never sure
really that we experienced
or witnessed what we think
we witnessed or experienced.
And this is what happens
to the character,
who thinks he sees something
and then draws a very
controversial cartoon
which has a strong impact
on somebody else's life.
And so, years later he doesn't
really know what was there.
>> Scott Simon: I think a lot of
Americans who read about the life
of Richard Nixon might be
reminded it's sometimes hard
to enlist a sympathetic memory for
Richard Nixon for many Americans.
But there was perhaps the great
political cartoonist of his time,
Herb Block of Washington Post,
did a very noteworthy caricature,
day after day obviously in the
news of this very swarthy, bearded,
sort of 5 o'clock shadow Nixon.
And he told interviewer
a number of years ago
that he would bring the Post in
when it was delivered in the morning
so his daughters wouldn't see it,
because he didn't want
his daughters --
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yes.
I got the story, or
variations of that story,
quite often while I was
researching for the novel.
Perhaps the greatest
cartoonist of his generation
in Columbia is called
Vlado [phonetic].
His pen name is Vlado.
He has become a friend of mine
since the writing of the novel
because he was a source
of information for me,
an invaluable source of information.
And one of the stories
he told me was
that once he had started
making cartoons
of this very powerful military
man in Columbia, who at the time,
used these dark glasses,
sort of Pinochet style.
And he had very crooked teeth,
extremely crooked smile.
And this is the way he was drawn.
So one day my friend the
cartoonist gets this message from --
I think he was a general --
asking him for a meeting.
So when the general
asks the cartoonist
for a meeting, you understand --
>> Scott Simon: Did he drive
a tank up to his office?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: I
think there was nowhere to park.
In the meeting he said, "Look,
I have change my glasses.
I have gone to the dentist.
And you still draw
me as I was before.
Please don't do that.
My children hate the drawings.
They make fun of me.
My wife is sad, etc, etc."
My friend said, "General,
that money is down the drain,
because I will join you as I wish.
This is your cartoon persona and
this is what you will be in the eyes
of the Colombian public."
So this is the power they have,
which is sometimes unfair.
But you know, who cares.
[Laughter]
>> Scott Simon: Your work has
been described as a reaction
to magic realism, of which
we've read so much coming
from great Latin American authors.
How you feel about that?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: I think
that has always, even with the best
of intentions, has always
been oversimplified.
What I feel is gratitude
towards Garcia Marquez.
One of the great advantages --
Garcia Marquez doesn't need any kind
of presentation, but he is of
course credited with having
in a way invented this new lens
-- it was new in the 60's --
to examine Latin American
reality which is magical realism,
which was taken up by
writers all over the world.
So nobody ever asks Salman Rushdie
or Mo Yan in China or Ben Okri
in Nigeria or [Inaudible] in the
French Caribbean, how did they write
under the influence
of Garcia Marquez?
But I get that question
all the time.
[Laughter]
>> Scott Simon: Do you notice
how artfully I actually left
out his name?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Yes, very good.
>> Scott Simon: I was trying
to avoid asking you
for the umpteenth time.
Sorry.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
So the thing with this is
that this question that you
have so artfully not asked,
it presupposes there is a sort
of territorial relationship
and influence, that
influence is territorial.
It's justifiable, but it's
almost never true in literature.
The fact that I'm Colombian in
no way means that the influence
of the great Colombian writer
immediately falls on my shoulders,
like it's not influenced by
influenza, like you're going
through the streets
and somebody sneezes,
and you get magical
realism all of a sudden.
[Laughter] Writers, and Garcia
Marquez is the best example of this,
when he started writing novels,
there was no Columbia
novelistic traditions to speak of.
We had a couple of great novels, but
there was not a tradition as such.
And so, he decided his master
would be Faulkner because he wrote
about a world very similar to
the world of Garcia Marquez.
And then he got tired of Faulkner,
and, in a way, hired Hemingway.
Come, teach me how
to write short novels
with spare dialogues
and economic prose.
And so, Hemingway did
the trick for one book.
And so, this mixture of
influences, Faulkner, Hemingway,
Kafka -- a little bit of Kafka.
For his second novel,
"An Evil Hour,"
he copied Albert Camus, in a way.
And that cocktail -- none of
these writers were Colombian --
and that cocktail allowed
him to discover his voice,
the voice in which he wrote
"One Hundred Years of Solitude."
That is more or less the
way it worked for me.
I grew up with Garcia
Marquez as a reader.
I have always admired Garcia
Marquez as a novelist.
I think he is one of the two
or three great stylists
in the Spanish language.
But these images, these
characters that I had
in my head needed a different shape
than magical realism
was able to provide.
I found that in other Latin American
writers, such as Mario [Inaudible]
or Juan Carlos Zanetti from Uruguay.
I found that in American writers
like Philip Roth, in
European writers.
You don't want to know
the list of them.
But this is how influence,
in a way, happens.
You have this image in your
head, and you choose the writers
who have the tools you need to
make that become literature.
In my case, it wasn't
Garcia Marquez.
There is one advantage I have
over Garcia Marquez is the fact
that I write in a world in which
Garcia Marquez already exists.
He didn't.
He didn't write in a world in which
Garcia Marquez had already written
his wonderful novels.
So my tradition is better for
that fact and I'm lucky here.
So this is what happens.
>> Scott Simon: Yeah.
We want to invite your questions.
There are a couple of
microphones up here.
We'll tell you that this event
is being recorded for posterity,
so if you're wearing a T-shirt with
some kind of indiscreet slogan,
you might want to strip
to your waist.
[Laughter] Just do it
anyway -- we're all friends.
As people advance on the mic,
let me work in one more question.
You spent years living in
Europe, Paris, Barcelona.
Easier or harder to
write about Columbia
in Columbia than it was from Europe?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Both.
It was definitely easier in
the sense that that cliché,
that unique perspective to talk
about your own country that you need
to get out of the woods in
order to have a better look
at the whole thing,
that's really true.
But on the other hand, I
started writing novels in a world
in which the Internet was not
as all- pervading as it is now.
So for my first real novel,
which is called "the Informers,"
I didn't have a strong relationship
with the Internet at that time.
I wrote that novel in 2002,
so I remember perfectly having
to call my father and ask him
to go to such-and-such corner.
Tell me what you see there.
Are you able to see the door
where Jorge Eliécer Gaitán left the
building before he was murdered?
And so I had these informers that
allowed me to write my books.
>> Scott Simon: Yeah.
And now of course,
that's on Google maps.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Exactly.
>> Scott Simon: Has anyone
advanced on the microphones?
I don't hear.
Yes, by all means.
You first, sir.
>> Questioner: I'm curious.
Having seen the popular depictions
of things like narcos and whatnot
in popular culture, are there any
that you're particularly interested
in and would want to react to?
Say, for instance, from the
pervasiveness of Escobar
and thoughts about Columbia?
What are the things you mentioned
earlier that provoke you to respond?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: I
don't think we have enough time
to let's talk about one
of those things that are
in direct relationship with the
other part of your question.
I have always felt angry
and sad and disappointed
at this thing we have
called the war on drugs.
But I think it's a huge mistake.
It has been a huge mistake 30 years.
I think it has damaged and
destroyed people's lives
in a way that is not justifiable.
Because drugs are essentially --
this is the situation in my country
and this is the situation in America
too -- drugs are a twofold problem.
They are a public health issue in
that drug consumption is a problem.
And they are a public order
issue, in that the fact
that they are criminalized needs
to criminality, corruption,
enormous wealth in the wrong hands,
in the hands of the Mafia,
of criminal structures.
And that destabilizes
democracies, kills innocent people.
And I have always defended the
idea that decriminalization
of drugs would lead us
with only one problem.
The problem, how to solve the
fact that people take drugs
and that damages their health.
The enormous amount of
money we spend on the war
on drugs could be spent
on prevention,
treatment, education, etc.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Thank you.
So yeah, that's it.
As for narcos, I haven't
seen that show.
[Laughter]
>> Scott Simon: Yes, sir?
>> Questioner: First of all, thank
you for a wonderful interview,
both Mr. Vasquez and to Scott Simon.
Every Saturday for me begins
with Scott Simon on NPR.
This is been wonderful to see.
>> Scott Simon: Thank you.
That's very kind of you to say that.
It's a great privilege to be
able to talk to so many people.
Thank you.
>> Questioner: I have two questions.
One is -- how are the
libel laws in Columbia
and do they protect
political cartoons?
You mentioned the general
and the journalist.
Was there any corrective
action taken
against the journalist
by the general?
That's number one.
And number two, since you mentioned
that you are a political columnist,
and I hope I'm getting
my facts right,
a year ago there was an
agreement [inaudible].
I just want your commentary
on how does all that progress,
because we heard there
was an agreement
and the agreement fell apart and
then something else was going on.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yeah.
That's kind of a long answer
too, one that I'm glad to give.
About the peace process, yes, there
was a successful peace process.
The first successful peace process
in the history of my country,
a country that has
been at war with itself
for the best part of
the 20th century.
This kind of violence began in 1948.
The FARC, the Marxist
guerrilla, was born in 1964.
The peace negotiations effectively
ended that war, a 52-year-old war
that had caused almost 7 million
victims, counting the dead,
the wounded, the displaced
population.
And that agreement sadly was
defeated in a referendum,
which to my mind was part of
the same international movement
of populism fueled with lies,
misrepresentations, and calamities
that caused Brexit and
a certain president.
[Laughter] That was a sad
day for Colombians who think
that the peace process, the
negotiation, was the way to go.
But after that, the agreements
were passed by Congress.
So they are being implemented
right now.
The parties modified the agreements
in almost every way that was asked
by the opposition, and they
are now being implemented.
There was a picture of the
paper six or seven months ago
in which the biggest room in
the military hospital in Bogotá,
a room that used to be
filled with wounded soldiers,
was empty for the first
time in 50 years.
[Applause] That was a good moment.
That's the situation.
And your other question was?
>> Questioner: The libel laws.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yeah.
Freedom of expression is
protected in very effective ways
in my country from what I can see.
That doesn't prevent the most
radical politicians to circumvent
that kind of thing
and attack journalists
through the social media
using lies, using calamities
to intimidate cartoonists, political
commentators, political journalists.
So it's a difficult situation.
I think social media has changed all
this relationship, all this world,
so dramatically that we are still
grasping with the consequences
of that in terms of the law.
We don't really know how that
works in this brave new world.
But I'm afraid that's all I can say.
Thank you.
>> Scott Simon: I'm going
to try and be respectful
of everybody's time here.
I know there's a lot to see
at this wonderful event.
That's get to as many questions
as we can, kind of make it
like the last round of
Jeopardy or something.
>> Questioner: Hello.
Have you ever thought
about modeling any
of your characters on
Father Camilo Torres?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
I didn't hear that.
>> Questioner: Camilo
Torres Restrepo?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Camilo Torres?
>> Questioner: Yeah.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Have I thought
of making him a character
in one of my books?
Well, no, but that's an
extremely good idea, my think.
Thank you very much.
>> Scott Simon: Do
you have an agent?
>> Questioner: Do you say
anything about [Inaudible]?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: What
do you think about [Inaudible]?
[Inaudible], in case he
is not familiar to you,
is the other great Colombian writer
in the generation of Garcia Marquez.
He was Garcia Marquez's friend in
many ways, a kind of accomplice,
I think, and mentor in a way.
He was an extremely generous
person, a wonderful writer,
although I prefer his
poetry to his prose.
But I think if his work
is translated English,
which I'm not sure about, I really
encourage you to read his work.
I share something with
him, and it's a fascination
for the work of Joseph Conrad.
So this is one thing
we have in common.
He is a great writer.
Thank you for bringing that name up.
>> Scott Simon: Yes ma'am?
>> Questioner: It's an
honor to meet you finally.
Your book "El Ruido de las Cosas al
Caer" is one of my favorite books.
My question for you is, what do you
consider is the role of literature
to heal the collective
grief of Columbia?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Wow!
We should get two hours
more for this conversation.
Let me put it this way; this is
the most succinct way I can find
of answering this question.
I think one of the things
we should be able to do --
ask Colombians right now with
this peace process going on,
is find a common narrative.
That is to say, this last 52 years
that the war lasted in Columbia,
that created so much suffering on so
many levels, so many different types
of violence on so many levels.
One story is told by a
victim of the guerrilla.
There are different stories
that are told by the victims
of the extreme right
wing [inaudible].
Different stories are told by
an inhabitant of the cities.
And a different story if
it's being told by a peasant.
So what do we do with this?
I think this where
literature can step in and try
to reconcile all the different
versions of our last 50 years,
or try to communicate the idea
that having all these very different
versions is not a handicap.
It's good.
This is what democracy is
about, telling different stories
about the same thing and having them
all be part of the Colombian story.
So this is, I think,
what we should try to do.
This is the reason I
write novels in a way,
to try to validate a certain version
of history of our common past,
keeping in mind that it's different
from other versions,
and that's good.
So, yeah.
>> Scott Simon: Yes, ma'am?
>> Questioner: That sort
of leads into my question.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Good.
>> Questioner: Do you think
novelists are esteemed
or valued differently in Columbia
and they are in this country?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez: Yes.
Yes, I didn't really do.
I think for reasons that
would be too long to explain
and that I don't really understand
completely, the position of a writer
in the American tradition is
different from the position
of a writer in the Latin
American tradition.
Maybe because, as Latin Americans,
we come from the French
ideal of the intellectual.
So novelists are expected to
participate in the political debate,
to participate in the social
debates of their time.
In that changes the
situation of writers.
I don't think an American novelist
would be expected immediately
to have all the answers ready
as to the political situation
of their country at
any public event.
As Latin Americans, we know
we are, and it's not easy.
And we always have to keep in mind
that ours is the tradition also
of such great writers that
shapes 20th century literature
as Jorge Luis Borges, who is not
in any recognizable
way a political writer.
He was not a political writer
in the sense that Garcia Marquez
or Mario Vargas Llosa were.
So we have both worlds
in Latin America,
but there is this expectation that
novelists should fulfill that idea.
It's not always fair.
Garcia Marquez himself said the
writer's only task is to write well.
Some days I agree with him.
Some days I don't.
I think that's the
main difference, yes.
>> Scott Simon: Juan Gabriel
Vasquez, it's been a great honor
for me to be his interlocutor here.
Thank you very much.
The book we spoke about
is "Reputations."
You'll be available to sign
the odd copy if someone asks?
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Yes, as many as you want.
>> Scott Simon: I believe, as
we say in the United States,
you'll sign until the
cows come home.
Thank you very much for joining us.
It's been great.
>> Juan Gabriel Vasquez:
Yes, thank you.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.